الى المسجد القبلي والى امام المجلس
القبلي
الانظار العاصمه
بدات التكبيرات
المرابطين والمرابطات بدات التكبيرات لكي
تمنع هذه المجموعه من التقدم في طريقها ها
هي اصوات المرابطات والمرابطين يحتفون
الله اكبر وهذه المجموعه الان بدات في
التقدم للامام المسجد القبلي كما اشرت
هناك فرقه الاسرائيليه امامها وفرقها من
الخلف سيوفر لها عماد
ويتقدمون باتجاه باب الرحمه هذا المسلك
الذي يتقدمون فيه وربما في الخطوات
القادمه ربما يبداون ايضا في التواجد
فالمراطبات الان بدات الاصوات تعلو بدات
الاسواق تعلو وتهزف الله اكبر بدا تهدف
الله اكبر الله اكبر ربما تسمعها اخي محمد
ها هم المرابطات الان يحدثنا الله اكبر
الله اكبر
وانا
اسير خلف المجموعه الاولى من الجماعات
اليهوديه المتطرفه ربما الان ابعد عنها
حوالي خمسه امتار فقط وتتقدم هذه المجموعه
الان
بالطريقه او المملكه الذي هو ايضا معد من
شرطه الاسرائيليه لها وتقدمت هذه المجموعه
كما اشرت بها اطفال وبها ايضا حسمات وبها
نساء من الجماعات اليهوديه
المتوارثه ها هي المجموعه تتقدم شيئا
فشيئا باتجاه باب الرحمه هناك ربما ستكون
الصلوات التلموديه التي دائما ما يكون لها
في تلك المنطقه ها هي الالتهابات مره اخرى
تعود الشرطه الاسرائيليه تمنع المرابطات
من التكبير وتمنع الشباب الفلسطيني من
التكبير
معاذ مره اخرى الى التكبير وربما منع هذه
الجماعات من التحرك بحريه ها هي مجموعه
اخرى ايضا من المرابطات والمرافقين ايضا
يهتف الله اكبر الله اكبر محمد الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
ربما تسمع